les murs beiges du ch est celle des
sainte anne de beaupré et l'étroitesse
de sa chambre seront bientôt chose du
passé pour jonathan marchand on va faire
du poney d'un contre des gros gains un
projet pilote pour sortir les adultes
handicapés des chs ld est en préparation
au québec sont entrées en vigueur est
prévue l'été prochain
une énorme victoire pour monsieur
marchand qui est atteint de dystrophie
musculaire et qui avait fui son ch et
celle des pour manifester devant
l'assemblée nationale l'été dernier qui
ont démontré dans les derniers morceaux
importants pour régler notre vision et
ça c'est très encourageant
on ne sait pas combien de personnes
pourront bénéficier de ce projet pilote
mais chose certaine le gouvernement ne
veut pas créer de nouveaux programmes en
travers d'un contexte actuel avec les
crochets dans avec existants de jonathan
marchand est convaincu que c'est
possible parce que sa propre situation
est sur le point de changer son traité
dans ce gros phares dont une récemment
on lui a octroyé un soutien à domicile
24 heures sur 24 avec le programme du
chèque emploi service il embauchera et
paiera lui même les préposés de son
choix je vais pouvoir recruter des gens
là pour m'aider dans mon quotidien
donc jours des gens qui ont cru de jodo
de nuit jeu deux fois
des discussions sont en cours pour que
jonathan déménage bientôt dans une unité
située à même le bâtiment de son ch et
celle d où il nous avait rencontré il ya
deux ans et d'ici six mois il devrait
avoir son propre logement en ville
fonctionne de bonheur doit d'avoir accès
au service de tous tes poveda communauté
en 2010
malgré les bonnes nouvelles jonathan
marchand n'en démord pas un jour les
lois devront aussi être révisé pour
favoriser une meilleure intégration
sociale des personnes handicapées ici
alexandre duval radio canada québec